with the Golden State Warriors we're
seeing an impending youth movement and
with that comes a difficult conversation
not sure if you guys saw it last night
Klay Thompson pulled in the fourth
quarter for younger players expressed
his frustration and how hard it was to
deal with here is some of his sound
after the
game that's all good these guys play
great he play great PP
jonan day winning troops off is this is
this an adjustment period for you a
little bit I mean he's done it in a few
games obviously yeah kiding me know
from you know one of the best
players it's hard for anybody you know
I'll be honest with you I've accepted it
but can be mad but I'm not be mad I'm
happy for these young guys honestly and
uh yeah we won and it's hard to get wins
in not hard to read the emotions on his
face it's been an incredible journey
watching clay and Candace you uh had
some feelings about this no I think
um everybody has their time right like
I'm crossing that bridge right now where
your mind still thinks that you can do
things that you cannot physically do and
you know that in your Prime you would be
cooking all of these people but you
literally cannot and I think
just clay so humbly has allowed us to be
along that Journey and a lot of people
go through it without four championships
or without reaching the success that he
has reached but it every time it's an
ending right like everybody worries
about who starts the game but the real
ones know it's who finishes it and so I
think that
that's the difficult pill to swallow I
think it's one of those things where
it's you don't want to leave something
because we've seen a dynasty break and
and Tony Parker went somewhere else and
it just wasn't the same right but also
he can't be what he was on Golden State
and he knows that and I think it's just
we're you know we're watching that and
as a player it it is really tough I mean
Shaq I know like when you're at a 10
most of your career and you start going
to
eight it's hard to believe but the
mentality that you have you always say
I'm gonna get it back I'm gonna get it
back when you trying to win and rebuild
we don't have time to wait they want you
to be at a 10 and you know I I I still
have confidence in them I still have
faith in them but you know we get older
you know they're saying that father time
is undefeated and he he can gladly say
he's one of those players that Father
Time defeated I'm one of those players
you can't say another guy outplayed me
or you know overworked me Father Time
Shaq got older he faded away so you know
he's he's starting to fade away but our
mentality is we can get it back we can
get it back we can get up so when you
put a younger guy and he's doing what
what you used to do and then you get a
crazy reporter ask you the question and
kind of kind of you know makes it you
know sink in a little more but has
nothing to be ashamed of it happens to
everybody except one guy you know he's
still dunking Tomahawk 30 40 but uh he's
uh listen he he done it his way he won
his championship respectfully go down
was a Hall of Famer was one of the
greats in Golden State and it's nothing
to be ashamed of but I know what he's
thinking I'm going to get it back I'm
going to get it back I'm going to get it
back and hopefully he does get it back
Jamal you played two decades in the NBA
and it's I I left how I came in too you
played 20th damn went I was 51 know that
like a g
notc not a a b or c I like a g no and
and so 31 for the I mean our first year
here you were like I can go score 20
right now yeah it's it's so interesting
though because you guys are you're I'm
not going to say it you're in your 30s
right you say it 37 okay fine I never
know how old are you you not say I know
Timeless wow anyway but what I mean is
is that's young in the grand scheme of
things but actually he can we were
somewhere and I was in the gym where we
at Shaq we were in Boston last year in
the playoffs I'm going and Jamal's
killing everybody the gym Shaq stopped
by spos stopped by yes just watching you
cook people want to see if I give him a
10 day but what I what I was getting at
is you guys are young in life but in
basketball this has been your entire
life and as that comes to a close it
feels like the ending of a chapter and
we're watching him experience this in
real time where it's not like sudden
it's like gradually throughout the
season for you I guess you go out with
51 you didn't have it like that but it's
as someone that's competed with him and
and understood him as a friend it's
interesting to watch it is and everybody
would tell you if you play the game long
enough from childhood to this point
you're going to experience every role
star player bench player rotation player
that's just part of the game if you're
blessed enough to play that long Klay is
still having a good season he's just not
having a clay season so he's comparing
himself to himself but I think what
bothers him more than anything is right
now and I haven't talk to him but it
just feels like listen to his interview
he feels like they may have lost faith
in him finishing games like cace said
that's the most important part he hasn't
finished games a few in a row now right
if I'm not mistaken at least three of
the last four whatever it is
and so for him to have to look at your
athletic mortality is a problem we all
face it right even with me I could shake
people but I wouldn't get in the same
separation I'm like damn he's still
right there you know what I mean so you
feel it and you see it and it's the
truth there's no way around it but
everybody's had to go through it clay
will bounc back he has good people
around him he'll see the good things
that's that can come out of this listen
Isaiah is Isaiah Thomas I remember I
asked him one night at NBA TV I'm like
you you stopped playing pretty early
like you had some more seasons left and
he was like it just wasn't fun anymore
like when you can you know what you're
capable of and you can't do it anymore
on a consistent basis like the the game
isn't Fun clay is used to coming in and
being game six clay in OKC and he's used
to everybody seeing that clay and that's
his level in standard and that's why
he's been the best one of the best
shooters ever but he's still he's
working and operating under and Steph is
too but Steph's a alltime great he's
operating with less space than he's had
since he's arrived so it only takes a
second to mess with your shot that close
out now from there is now right here it
can mess with your
percentage